we've been looking at this strange
triangle and we have noticed that
despite how simple it is is lot in there
right it's one of my favorite things
simple things that you can think about
deeply they're kind of like some of my
favorite objects and this is one of them
I'll give you a quick example of one we
haven't looked at before I will show you
look at all the numbers that are there I
want you to have a look at this time we
sort of have multiples in this before
right for instance last time we talked
about all of the prime Rose except for
the ones on the outside in prime Rose
all of the terms are multiples of that
prime number that's a big weed that's it
for example if I went out to the 73rd
tapeline right all of the numbers in the
thirteenth line which we have a
calculator we can check on now right for
example if I say Oh 13 see 7 I have no
idea what that number is okay actually
well I don't need to wonder what that
number is let's quickly break it up okay
it's going to be and this someone can
beat me to it
1716 okay the 1007 under 16 5 divided by
13 is 132 right so we've seen these
weird patterns there are more I just
quit quickly quickly show you one
let's pick multiples but this time let's
just look broadly right now have a look
at same multiples off you can pick any
number but being that I haven't drawn
that much of it I'm gonna pick multiples
of three okay so if you look for where
the multiples of three are where is the
first of all to fill three it's three I
see one there and I see you on there I
go down I see another multiple three yep
okay now how far you have to go before
you see the next one
okay high five for an attempt but what
merit nor very Mariana I have symmetry
what's that about
Wi-Fi shapes like that okay I'll try let
me do another one let me do another one
that was multiples of three yeah how
about even numbers I'm gonna do they're
these boxes this time what where else
what's going on I'm seeing all these
upside down triangles now all of that to
say what I encourage you to do is draw
more rows or go back to where you've
drawn like I think I went to eleven on
one of the lessons right go do what you
see more and see how many patterns you
can find it all of that just to prove to
you that even though it's built in a
very simple way right there are paths
like it looks like you would only expect
patterns between these two numbers and
the next ones down but the patterns get
all over the place okay so in order to
investigate one of the most important
patterns in fact the pattern that gives
us the binomial theorem I could pick any
of these rows but I'm gonna pick the
sixth row I think it's the UM the
easiest one of you is also a discernible
pattern okay we're used to generating
each of the terms like when I actually
go ahead and write the next line okay I
write one and then I write eight and 28
and 56 and so on right but the way I
form the numbers as I look at this is
I'm actually not paying attention at any
of these numbers and how they relate to
each other I'm actually paying attention
to the world Bob right but my whole
point about noticing what this reader
patent is that this should be
connections along the road like I should
be able to like without this row up here
I think I should be able to work out one
number to the next because it's such a
structured thing right so I'm expecting
this some kind of pattern here so I'm
going to look at row number six and see
if there's a patent and then if I can
identify what I'm going to try to
generalize I think so here we go
I'm going to name each of the terms here
I'm going to name them using the NCR
notation that we introduced and then
while back right I'm going to use the
short form so the first term should be
like this six C zero right okay so
that's equal to one that's fine you
already knew that I can write out all of
the rest of the terms let's just quickly
do that the next one is going to be six
we go all the way down 15 20 back to 15
and you're getting the picture
as we anticipated you've got MC 0 which
is 1 and NC n which is also one that was
one of the first properties we noticed
okay now what can we do with this I was
trying to suggest to you that not only
can we like look at the role bulb to
generate the next row I think we should
be able to generate each term each
successive term with all the previous
term so example to go from here to here
turn 0 term 1 hmm what's the difference
how do I do it
I can think about this two ways I can
think about this additively right so the
difference between here's 5 the distance
from here to here is 9 this is your gear
here is 5 and then it goes back by and
then 9 and then 5 hmm that's kind of
interesting that's kind of interesting
right gap of 5 gap of 9 gap of 5 5 again
that's kind of strange but I kind of
well now I'm stuck I don't know what to
do with that ok you might like to have a
look at other and see if something else
is there but as I said before one of the
best ways to try and work and massage a
mathematical problem is to look at from
another angle so instead of looking from
the angle addition I'm gonna think about
multiplication before I do this this
should actually make sense to us because
how do we introduce this topic we were
looking at these guys right and these
are born out of multiplication it's 1
plus X times 1 plus X total so we ought
to expect that multiplication won't have
something to do with this so I'm just
gonna get rid of these for a second cuz
just we're gonna have a lot of
information on there in a second said
the less the better how do I get
multiplicatively
I think that's a word from this number
this number what do I do
all I have to do is multiply by 6 that's
6 by 1
yeah okay how do I go from this term 6
to this one
this is six times something
what's it times what well I mean it's an
easy way of doing it is to say well it's
15 over six isn't it which i think is
2.5 okay fifteen over six I can read
that a little simpler right I can write
that as stricted over six as a fraction
let's bring it down it's five on three
right 595 or two I went to that's the
simplest way which is the two and a half
you taught me before yeah
okay let's go to the next one I'm
starting with 15 what do I multiply by
in order to get to 20 I can't think of
it as 20 or 15 or more simply for on
three I'm still getting bigger honor I'm
gonna write both of them 2150 which is
four on three
are there any patterns there that you
can see let's let's keep going okay stay
with me stay with me now by this time
I've already gone as far up as I need
you like the rest of it is just symmetry
so you can tell me this just in Reverse
right this one's going to be 20 times
what 3 on for it's this right 15 over 20
this right
what's this one this is going to be that
15 times 6 over 15 which we noticed
before that's 2 fits and then here I've
got my 6 and then I multiplied by 1 over
6 and I can't simplify any more okay now
you're starting to see the pattern
starting to see it if not that's okay I
can see it easy because I've seen this
hundreds of times by the way just a
quick question you saw we sort of went
this way right I kind of skipped this
guy because it's like well he's won but
can you see there is something I can
what could I like we when I with the
package on this way so what with a
pattern look like
that way I'm gonna leave him for a
second we'll come back to here because
the whole thing about patterns is if
they really work they always work right
if you really know the pattern now to
make this even more clear sorry I have
so many calls on the board but thanks
let me clarify this a little more see
how I've got two kids here and then
three quarters and then four thirds and
then five over two that tells me this is
not really a one is it what should that
really be ha ha it's a six over one
thank you can you see it cuz look this
numerator as I go up is increasing and
the denominator is decreasing okay here
we go now I'm gonna try and write this
thing up this guy this is 6 over 1 times
5 over 2 right this is 6 over 1 by 5
over 2 by 4 over 3 following what's this
guy this is all of the previous ones 6
over 1 by 5 over 2 by 4 over 3 times the
new one ok you can see the pattern I'll
cut you what am I gonna have you 6 over
1 5 over 2 403 354 205 and then here
six five four three two one
okay now that you've got you two
canceling here which is why he ended
with one right
I started completed this picture yeah
but that's okay to help me complete it
I'm gonna go one more step look at this
this is a disaster right mathematicians
hate writing more than they ever need
you particularly when there's a pattern
you've been taken by juggling right so
for instance let's pick one how about
how about this line here okay see how on
the top there I have six times five all
right six times five okay but we have
learned notation that makes it easier to
write six times five knowing that what I
really mean is just close the next one
this starts like six factorial starts
doesn't it it begins the same way six by
five by but then it stops it's missing
the four three two one
so I'm missing four factorial
do you agree with that so to write six
by five I write six factorial on
full-fat world is that okay that's just
the numerator now I have the denominator
what's the denominator it's two times
one it's two factorial right okay keep
helping me what's this what's this new
era six by five by four it starts just
like six factorial but what's it missing
it's missing the 3 factorial isn't it
right it's gonna be 6 factorial on 3
factorial that's just the numerator and
then I've got 3 2 1 I've got another
three factorial there okay I can stop
thinking part I kinda look I've got that
six factorial on the top but I'm missing
the true factorial over here so I divide
and then there's a fourth factorial okay
six factorial on the top I'm missing the
one factorial I know that doesn't matter
but you can see the pattern 5 factorial
6 factorial on huh no I'm gonna come
back to that a second before we address
that let's finish this thing let's
finish this thing um if I got one factor
of 5 effect or two effect over 4
factorial etcetera what's this it should
be six on which of course is just six
and this guy is successor on which of
course is one okay now we remember I
posed to you the question a little while
back and I said why I said why what I
mean that's just weird okay no it's not
weird
it's the only result that makes any
sense of this situation right because if
it's not one everything just explodes it
has to be one right so can you see the
pattern